I'm Gary Stevenson welcome back to Gary's
Economics today we're going to talk about Politics
okay so there have been three big developments
recently in politics that you need to understand
when we look at each of them initially they
they might look like things that are worth
celebrating but they're all going to present
problems you need to know what they mean for
you so that you can react to it so the three
things are number one the government has rode
back on basically all of the disaster budget
from a few weeks ago number two it looks
very possible that Liz Truss will leave as prime
minister and conservative party leader very soon
and number three it's become very likely
that labour will win the next election
we're going to talk about all three of those
things one at a time so we're going to start
with the first thing which is the reverse of the
budget so you probably know there was a disaster
budget a few weeks ago where the conservative
Government tried to slash taxes massively for the
richest there's a video on the channel which you
can go watch if you haven't seen about that budget
um they've reversed nearly everything there so
people who watch the channel will know I was
massively against that budget so it's easy to
think they've reversed the budget that's going
to be fantastic until you see what it looks
like they're going to replace the budget with
so it looks like they've moved basically
to a new version of austerity which means
cutting budgets for public services education
Healthcare local Services police now these are all
things which I've already had their budgets cut
massively in the austerity government from 2010.
so if we cut these things again we're basically
looking at a situation where there's pretty much
nothing left to cut you are cutting into the bone
here so if we move into an austerity situation
you're talking about basically dismantling the
basic services that allow this country to function
dismantling the police dismantling the schools
dismantling the NHS totally getting rid of local
services this is already at a time when ordinary
families are really struggling um I don't think I
really need to get into the details of what this
will mean for ordinary families what it will mean
for you for your community for your family if this
happens it will have a devastating impact not only
that but it will mean more job cuts for people who
work in public services that will mean more people
competing for the existing jobs it will mean wages
will probably fall or struggle to rise definitely
struggle to rise with inflation so less money in
your pocket less money going around the economy
um yeah more collapse it's a disaster basically
I want to talk a little bit about why that has
happened why we've moved from a situation of let's
cut taxes on rich people to instead let's cut
Public Services this has happened because a space
has been opened up in the narrative saying oh it's
not possible to cut tax on rich people because the
markets won't accept it which essentially means
we cannot borrow that amount of money and we have
then gone automatically back to the previous sort
of narrative framework of well then we have to
have austerity now this is only possible because
the alternative option of instead let's tax
rich and very rich people more has basically
been completely removed from the conversation now
people who follow this channel will know that the
last three years have seen the biggest and fastest
ever increase in wealth of the rich and the super
rich the average rich person increased To Us by 22
in the first year of covert alone uh the average
billionaire increased the wealth by 620 million in
the first of covid the total amount of government
of money that has gone from the government to
the rich is 600 billion pounds which would be 12
000 pounds for every adult in the country
so we are in a space here where the
government has effectively transferred
an enormous amount of money to the rich
if we were to tax that back we could give it to
you we could cut your taxes we could improve a
living stance for ordinary people we wouldn't
have to cut Public Services but unfortunately
this is just totally not in the conversation right
now nobody's talking about taxing rich people and
if we allow that to be the main frame of
debate then we end up in a situation where
the only alternative is cutting public services so
I think this really emphasizes how important it is
that we do not let them ignore this possibility
look at the same time as ordinary families are
literally struggling to eat we have seen the
biggest and fastest ever historic increase in
millionaire and billionaire wealth we need to
get taxi rich people into the conversation okay
so that's number one covered they've rode back
on the budget but they're bringing in well it's
quite probably a worse budget for ordinary people
they will be allowed to do that as long as we do
not get tax in the rich back on the conversation
so you need to talk about tax in a rich more you
need to persuade your friends and family that is
important number two is is list trust potentially
leaving now we're filming this in the beautiful
rain on Thursday morning uh this video will come
out on Sunday morning it's quite possible that
list trust will already be gone by then we totally
don't know she might limp on into next year but
it at this point it's almost certain she will
not be conservative leader for the next election
um listen I'm not a big fan of this trust I don't
think anyone would be surprised to hear that I
thought that her Economic Policy was a disaster
thought that her budget was a disaster it would be
tempting to celebrate this trust leaving but the
fact is she will be replaced probably by another
austerity prime minister I don't need to tell you
how bad that is going to be for for you for your
community for this country or for the economy so
we shouldn't be celebrating her leaving because
it's not going to make things better things are
going to continue to get worse now the third one
I think is the most interesting one and definitely
something we need to talk about a lot which is
it is becoming increasingly clear that it is
very very likely label win the next election
quite possibly even with an outright majority
um betting markets are starting to think this is
60 likely something like this I actually think
it's more likely than that the reason I think
that is because it is becoming inevitable now that
living standards and the economy will continue to
collapse seriously over the next couple of years
um in that situation is inevitable that support
for the government will fall and fall and fall
and that means that very likely they will win
the next election some people are saying that
there's a prospect of a labor government very
soon realistically the timing of the election is
almost completely in the power of the conservative
government they know that if they have an election
shortly they will get smashed most of the MPS
will lose their seats they'll lose their jobs so
it's very likely they will not call a short-term
election and the election will be 2024 maybe even
the very beginning of 2025. so we probably do
have another couple of years of this government
the conservative government um the economy will
almost certainly be disaster throughout that time
but after that we'll probably get a labor
government um now anyone who watches this channel
will know that I've not been a big supporter
of the current conservative government and some
people may have assumed from that that means I'm a
massive supporter of Labor that's not really true
my situation is if you do not do something about
massively rapidly increasing wealth inequality
you are going to decimate living standards of
ordinary people and Ordinary People are going
to lose their wealth they are going to suck the
wealth out of the middle class of this country
um but it has become increasingly obvious to me in
the last few months that labor is very very likely
to come into government before too long so I went
to the labor party conference and I've been I've
been getting contacted by some labor MPS and I've
been reaching out to them to try and speak with
labor MPS basically to see is there a possibility
that that they are going to increase tax on very
rich people because I think if we don't do that
it is inevitable that we'll have a disaster um and
I have to tell you honestly the sense I'm getting
from the people that I've spoken to is that labor
are not serious about significantly raising taxes
on rich people you know um I can't mention that
people individually who I've been speaking to but
I spoke to some people recently about the prospect
of raising a one percent wealth tax on wealth
assets above 10 million pounds and even that
doesn't look like we're going to get it so you
know you need to think about somebody with worth
above 10 million pounds right they make three
four five percent on that every year so all
we're talking about is slowing down by a fraction
the rate at which wealth inequality increases and
labor at the moment does not seem serious about
supporting it so but what does that mean that
means that realistically what is probably going to
happen here is the conservative government limps
on for another couple of years they get replaced
by labor government that labor government doesn't
understand the seriousness of reducing wealth
inequality so they raise taxes on rich people
extremely slightly and all that does is slow down
the rate at which wealth inequality is increasing
now you probably don't need me to tell you that
in the last few years wealth inequality which
has been increasing for decades now in the last
years it's gone massively accelerated the speed
at which World inequality is increasing at this
point if we don't do something very serious to
stop that massive wealth transfer from ordinary
families and from the government to the rich
before long we will totally lose amid the class
and within a generation or two we will become a
very very unequal country if we don't take action
on it that is what's going to happen it looks
like labor is not going to take Serious enough
action on it what that means is label get into
power and they will oversee continual worsening
in the economy so under labor they'll probably
slightly slow down what I think we honestly
have to say has been a collapse in living
standards they will slow down that collapse
but living standards will continue to fall
they will probably stay in government for four
or five years under slowly worsening conditions
slowly falling living standards understandably
people are going to get pissed off and there's
a very real possibility that people are going
to sit there and they're going to say well
the conservatives didn't do nothing for
us labor didn't do nothing for us let's
look for something more extreme and
there's a very real possibility that
we move towards some sort of extreme far-right
government that is pushing policies that are
maybe more explicitly racist or explicitly
aggressive you know we had a period before where
we had an explosion inequality and an economic
crisis and it led to fascism throughout Europe the
Holocaust and the second world war you know this
has happened before and I know that sounds extreme
but I'm sitting here I'm looking at a country
that's getting increasingly frustrated they are
going to vote in a labor government and when
I talk to the labor politicians they do not
understand at all the seriousness of the problem
here they are going to get in they are not going
to deal with wealth inequality wealth inequality
will get worse and the economy will get worse and
then really honestly God knows what happens
after that politically um but when I speak
to them they say to me many of them we would
be happy to support a world tax but we don't
think it's a vote winner we think it's going to
lose us votes we think people don't support it
to me what that says to me is basically the
importance of what we are trying to do here
if we don't deal with wealth inequality the
rich will get massively richer ordinary families
will lose their homes they'll go further into
their government services will be ultimately
decimated the country will become phenomenally
unequal and living standards will collapse
um and unless you watching this are very rich
that's you your kids your grandkids your family
your communities living standards collapsing okay
you need to support High attacks on the richest
and you need to convince your friends and you need
to convince your family and you need to convince
your community and you know over the next few
weeks and months we're going to do a series of
videos explaining why it's important and hopefully
you can use that to understand it and to convince
the people around you but until enough Ordinary
People support it I can't turn around to labor
and make them do it So the plan here is that we
need to build a massive community of people who
understand the importance of wealth inequality
demand it from their political parties and spread
that message around because if enough people are
turning around to the labor party saying listen we
are only going to vote for you if you do something
about wealth inequality then I could turn around
to them and say you have to do it and they
can't turn to me and say well it's a vote loser
so um listen there's an opportunity here but at
the moment we're not making it at the moment labor
are going to come in and they're not going to fix
the problem and things are going to get worse we
can make things better if enough people understand
that the only way to improve living conditions for
ordinary families and ordinary people in this
country is to deal with wealth inequality so
you need to understand that you know go and watch
what is wealth go watch the first video on this
channel where covid-19 is making the rich richer
understand how wealth inequality affects you your
family or community and spread that message your
friends and family we're gonna try and grow this
to make it big we're gonna try and get people
to understanding this message and then hopefully
by two years time when labor coming into Power
I'm going to be able to look at them and say you
guys have to do this now um if we don't achieve
that these are going to be really bad so you know
I'm going to be out here in the rain making these
videos um hopefully you guys are going to support
um yeah follow us on all our channels we've got
Instagram and Facebook and Twitter and of course
YouTube press the Bell tell your friends tell
your family um we've got one opportunity here and
um if we don't take it um it's going to be bad
and we've got two years to do it so yeah get
behind the message and please support
us and and tell people yeah thank you
yeah be fine they just gradually got
more rainy as the video goes yeah
if you get a bit more money and
the rich get a lot more money you
will become poorer and you need to
have a policy which actively focuses
on reducing energy consumption of the
rich and support support it's not there